bonsoir colas caillère merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france quelles
réactions en israël après que la justice
française a jugé irresponsable
pénalement le meurtrier de sara lee me
il ya eu beaucoup d'échos colère et de
scandales
le ministre des affaires étrangères a
dit que sarah halimi a été tué car à
elle était juive à cause de
l'antisémitisme il a également qualifié
ce meurtre odieux disons qu'il a fait du
mal non seulement à la victime et à sa
famille mais également la communauté
juive et à sa capacité à se sentir en
sécurité à tel aviv des personnes de
registre française tout comme des
israéliens en général pense que c'est la
tulette en danger les plaintes et juifs
en france pour le gouvernement français
nous ne réussit pas à faire face aux
lames limite isme grandissant dans ce
pays justement c'était l'une de mes
questions cette affaire est-elle de
nature à impacter d'une manière ou d'une
autre l'image de la france en israël
c'est une possibilité du gouvernement
français est en israël et qu'il ya deux
poids deux mesures une clé trop sensible
la mairie
et avec beaucoup de jeunes comme et par
personne pour les israéliens si l'on se
ferait tuer réception des victimes de
racisme
alors on est excusé si les musulmans
français ne veut pas être accusée que
l'antisémitisme est un problème
croissant en france et que la france
vers les assassins de juifs plutôt que
de les juger correctement j'ai vu que ce
jugement était n'était pas juste et
qu'il faudrait revenir sur ce cas alors
il ya une plainte en israël il va y
avoir un la soeur de sarah halimi qui
espère bien la tenue d'un nouveau procès
la loi pénale d'israël le permet
quelle chance d'aboutir et sous quelle
forme en vertu de la loi pénale
israël est effectivement impossible
d'enquêter et de télé jc conférer sur
des crimes antisémites semaines à
l'étranger surtout s'ils sont dénoncés
par un citoyen faire de victimes et
israël sont chanceux battant procès
c'est que sans ça il est certain qu'en
israël on considère qu'il y à une
nouvelle souche est antisémitisme en
france notamment les salles de la
jeunesse une organisation israélienne
qui a des bureaux dans le monde entier
tlusty dix ans a dit que ce jugement
était un coup et sans précédent et
établissez une jurisprudence selon
laquelle des criminels pouvait dire
qu'ils étaient fous qu'ils étaient
drogués et qu'il ne pouvait donc pas
être tenu légalement responsable
ici en l'occurrence une personne a été
tuée et le criminel attaque les livres à
ne pas se rendre sur les lieux du crime
et il peut certainement accroché être en
contact et d'autres personnes juives
il peut continuer à consommer du
cannabis la raison de ce crime
en premier lieu tout ce que vous venez
nous expliqué paula ça pousse de
nombreux juifs français
à émigrer en israël ce qu'on appelle la
lia il y en a de plus en plus
encore aujourd'hui effectivement
fassions vers l'israël assez forte
depuis la france au cours des dernières
années mais il ya une communauté
française passe en israël et en
constater également que beaucoup de
juifs français des machettes était
appartenant en escale maïs et les vives
par tout cela j'ai lâché volume ou si
l'on cause ira car si la situation
empire en france alors qu'ils auront la
possibilité d'efferalgan d'israël
glorieuse déploré devoir accélérer cette
caisse dur mais qu'il ne plaît pas à
cesser ce déni de justice de france est
allée contre la raison senti insulté la
communauté juive en france et dans le
monde parti en france 5 mais la suivre
également la situation en france et
beaucoup pensent que la même chose
pourrait se reproduire dans d'autres
pays
doucement avec d'autres gouvernements
est ce bien commun leur propre
gouvernement réagirait
merci pour la sla fière d'avoir été avec
nous en direct de tel aviv